[Music]
it is a big show today it is a big show
today at the very end I got an
announcement on who the super special
secretive gambling analytics expert that
will be joining competing and battling
with me on every gambling show during
the season that's at the end of the show
in the middle of the show I'm gonna go
through and I'm gonna tell you who I
picked to win every division in the NFL
my two wild-card teams we're gonna go
through the playoffs we're gonna pick a
Super Bowl I have not even done the
playoffs so when we get there it's all
coming straight off the top of the dome
I'm giving you my MVP my Defensive
Player of the Year and let's just say
the left go notebook right now is flush
I have never taken this many copious
notes I have more information on
injuries than I've ever had
I have gambling analytics and trends and
nuggets that I hope that when I get done
today you will look at teams differently
but to my left as he has been there for
the last few months mr. Engler to your
left I'm also a lefty and so it like
pains me to see a notebook where you're
not even using that side of the notebook
for the people that are just okay so you
like to leave half the pages open so
that you can take more notes so we're
gonna get into it I am I
I spent time about two weeks ago going
every year I'm really prepared for weeks
1 through 3 and then the [ __ ]
that is the NFL keeps going what kind of
a system can I create where I can just
keep adding to things and then get
better so this is a system born out of
practice repetition Cal this a few weeks
ago okay you got two notebooks going
notebooks so this is going to be my
weekly notebook in which I am going to
have throughout the the Sundays keeping
track of all the games all the lines
everything this is going to be major
injuries this is going to be major news
headlines that everyone's talking about
I'm breaking it down so that when I get
ready for the podcast on Monday
therefore you that I can go and then I
can also look back four weeks ago a
member when everybody was questioning
Sean Payton's job like stuff like that
that would be a fun thing if you had one
of these notebooks and just every year
you had it and you have a big shelf
where you can go all the way back to
like H I have those four drafts I have
the last five six years in copious notes
for drafts it started because I have a
family friend named Jason stark who's
now in the Baseball Hall of Fame that
you know when you have a family friend
you're coming up in the business and you
just ask them questions randomly or use
the ESPN baseball writer oh yeah Jason
start growing up so me and his daughter
were friends we went to school together
how cool and different stops along the
industry he would give me like 20
minutes to talk on the phone and he told
me one time I said how do you keep up
with all the news and he had one
notebook for the AL and one notebook for
the NL and every morning he would open
the newspaper and he would spend time
writing the little pieces of information
down and then when I got into the
industry and the internet started
getting good I was like why do I need to
do that it's right there hmm but there's
so much information and for me as a
kinesthetic learner I began to realize
when I write things down
I remember them a lot more 100% it was
true if I ctrl-c ctrl-v copy and paste
I'm not retaining anything and so this
is borne out of my own habit and then I
really got to know Ernie Johnson mm-hmm
and Ernie Johnson is to the 20th degree
where I asked him one time we're on the
way to a Dan Patrick show and he was the
guest and I was a guest and he showed me
his manila folder that had like 50 pages
of notes and in the middle way through
the show the drive I said have you had
any like vacation time he goes honestly
I'm gonna feel bad saying this but my
wife and the kids went down to South
Carolina and I had two days to myself
and you know I got myself a pizza and I
just got all of my notes done it was
amazing and what you just begin to
realize is if you're not making it a job
you're not going to be better than
anybody that's all so casually
watching and so I put the pressure on
myself that if I'm gonna sit up here and
people are gonna give a [ __ ] about what
I have to say I need to do this [ __ ] for
my own memory and then also so that me
and the guy at the bar don't have the
same take on sterling Shepherds thumb
injury right mm-hmm
yeah and as we talked about how takes
like in the same way that the vagus
lines can affect the way you think about
a game as soon as you see that the Rams
are favored by six you automatically
start thinking oh the Rams must be a lot
better right I think that's true too
with the media that you wake up you go
to your web sites you go to bleacher
report you go to the app you start
reading stuff on your fantasy web sites
and whatnot and then those just become
the takes in your brain yes as opposed
to if you just watch the game you come
up with your own takes and then you see
where that fits into the take ecosystem
a few days later that's you allow
yourself to have a more sort of cogent
voice and more unique voice so a lot of
the information that I'm using is people
that I respect one of them a lot of it
obviously is the warren sharp book where
the amount of analytics he has his use
of strength of schedule is pretty
incredible I focused on returns I will
explain that more when we're picking but
to get into the right mindset we need to
officially start to button up the
offseason and that's by doing maybe it
might be it's not the last time but it's
one of the final times of something we
like to call
[Applause]
[Music]
big offseason Nick nails the closer he's
this thin and there were this finger
over the button just ready for it big
offseason alright so uh where we start I
have three big ones but of course I have
an honorable mention to start things off
and it's by the way next Wednesday I've
just decided that will be the whoa big
offseason Awards okay yeah where we will
go back and look at all the woes we've
had before we will give out our award
for the woe of the offseason the whoa
the biggest off seasons of all the woes
it's been an incredible off season so
we'll kind of have an award show
yeah next Wednesday I really think it's
all Labor Day to think abut this needs
to be cigars and offs like at the ESPYs
there should be a category for the
biggest whoa I I really would you so
what would the award be it would just be
Nick's face with his hands on it like to
his cheeks like Macaulay Culkin going oh
you've a button the press in the bottom
of the trophy that makes that sound if
you had to boil down the trophy to
either Keanu Reeves or Joey from blossom
who gets them more like cuz one of those
guys not Nick no Nick Kiana's whoa is
iconic but it's not the whoa big
offseason that's whoa whoa whoa whoa I
know kung fu
yeah whereas the Joey from blossoms whoa
that's what way closer to a whoa big
offseason in my mind it is alright it
might just also be a cartoon bubble with
the word whoa I don't mind that either
marketing team figure that out for next
year we're the marketing team okay so
where are we started we're starting with
my man Eddie Panero Oh congratulations
wow what a kick this weekend yes no I'm
just saying there was a great article
that was very whoa bears kicker Eddie
Panera's final test slay Soldier Field
and they were talking about how he's
four and four four four four on the road
but he's only won 4-2 at Soldier Field I
love a small sample size which I love I
love that part of the issue with Chicago
pittsburgh's the same way where it's
they it's easier for the kicker on the
road and legitimately but also the fans
buy into it to where it's like please
slay our home dragon it's so hard to
kick at home I love that narrative but
for me what it comes down to and we were
just having a conversation the other day
about Drew Brees Peyton Manning versus
Tom Brady career numbers
that drew brees spent his whole career
in warm weather climates playing in a
dome and I think with kickers we have to
factor that in if you're talking about
the greatest kickers of all time being
really good you know in Chicago is very
different from being really good in
Atlanta and when you factor in like when
you say Vinatieri and you think of
elements we all think of the same thing
50 plus yard field goal in the snow tuck
Rule gauger at the same point the last
like decade he's been he's busy oh yeah
I still think of Adam Vinatieri as being
like oh he's been kicking in blizzards
for two year this is the best way to do
it to have it first like eight or ten
years of your career being an outdoor
Buffalo New England like that type of
environment and then you can go to some
cushy dome type place and it's like but
you've already got the bonafide he's
he's clutch he can play in cold he can
kick a frozen rock through 50 yards all
he has to do is slay soldiers honorable
mention okay first real honorable
mention gonna count back from three to
one
so the third ill whoa the bronze medal
Ted Karras Patriots offensive lineman
now that's David Andrews we wish you a
speedy recovery I hope he does well what
was his injury I believe it's blood
clots in his lungs so this is honestly
very scary so I'm noticing a trend I
didn't realize it was that Russell oh
[ __ ] for the Chargers has blood clots
and they're comparing his to Chris Bosh
I was thinking Chris Bosh when I read
the injury yeah and because what happens
is you have to start taking blood
thinners and then everything goes out of
whack but it is interesting that Tom
Brady's Center and the left tackle for
the Chargers two teams that are Super
Bowl contenders those are huge losses
absolutely you as a human please get
better David Andrew yeah that's the main
thing I especially like the week of
Andrew Luck retiring for mental and
physical health that's the main thing
when some guy gets injured especially
something as scary as blood clots in
your lungs we just wish you well I'm
gonna update my injury notebook but
please what's the whoa okay yes
Ted carrots they asked him because now
he's sliding in he's taken first team
reps as a center and they asked him
what's the difference between where you
normally line up on the offensive line
versus the center and we said quote my
favorite offensive line quote of the
year I've been doing it for a while I've
been doing it around here for a while
now you just come into work every day
it's not that much different you got to
snap the ball though that's the big
difference how great is that as a no
lineman with a huge beard just speaking
in a scrum no like so what's the
difference like well yeah you got to
snap the ball from this position but
other than that it's pretty much the
same and I was like yeah I think we'll
be okay I think that was from the Bill
Belichick 101 exactly media was perfect
yeah the other aspect too is I love when
offensive lineman I've heard this before
like was it between right guard and left
cards like try wiping your ass with the
other hand and it's like okay but I
think it is it's it's a big deal
oh my god is absolutely a big deal I
make you nervous as a Patriots fan
losing an offensive lineman losing your
centers like yeah I was gonna say losing
an offensive lineman that's bad enough
in terms of cohesive unit you want that
to be like five guys working in in
perfect synchronicity but losing your
Center that's a whole different thing
and you know based on your Ross Tucker
interview Tom Brady loves a good center
loves a good snap let's have a good snap
boys let's have a good snap here we go
good snap before every single scar neck
yeah that's the thing it's like I'm not
gonna lie so when I get later to like
picking divisions and all that they're
the only team that even if I find huge
issues with analytics and trends yeah
the Patriots are gonna figure it out
they just are knock on wood I hope so
knock out what if you're with me fellows
that's the best remix of hard knocks
this season uh hard knocks was good it
was good it was okay we can get into it
but grew didn't he said boof again he
did I noticed that I thought of you and
he said it was like now it's an
intentional or he listen you're
podcasting monitor that's right just
really quick really proud of Johnathan
Abram nail on the singing that's the
thing we've talked about in this podcast
before that being a great singer is not
about having a good voice it's about
winning over the room and he did he went
over the room it's great song choice
great charisma got people singing along
with him that's that's really great
karaoke 101 right there
great stuff okay whoa number two
counting down from three to one this is
from nola.com quote from Taysom Hill
your guy Oh cutie of the future back of
the Saints yeah quote I got very upset
about that by the way on social I'm look
that's what takes our for right and
people want to get upset yeah just
letting you know the teddy is very
average right now okay sorry Taysom Hill
has adopted drew brees his routines he
said I thought you're gonna say his kids
I was like this guy is so versatile
he's giving drew brees let's give mr.
hunts he can babysit tigré turn punts he
could turn movies he hurt dry cleaning
okay walk your dog
I do what Drew does he'll said with a
smile you could ask anybody here I
follow him around I've adopted his
schedule to how he studies for a game
how he prepares for a game both mentally
and physically obviously there's
something there so now now it's like
we're you know guy shadowing and other
guys that gonna bother drew brees is
that annoying it's great because of the
comedy that you could the length you
could take it to oh it's a sick guy just
walking taking a piss next to Drew you
know just copying everything eating the
same thing and like Drew Brees blows his
nose so taste them feels compelled to
grab a tissue to it but the thing that's
interesting is I remember when chase
Daniel was true breezes backup yeah and
then came to the Eagles and I will
always wish chase Daniel well because of
what he did for Carson Wentz one of the
woes that offseason was chase chase
Daniel had written down drew brees his
schedule so clearly that's how routine
based true breezes that multiple backups
are like I'm just gonna adopt it to the
point where he wrote down 705 eating
oatmeal 7:10 throw out the oatmeal and
he took it and he brought it to Carson
Wentz and Carson Wentz adopted it Wow
so I'm almost curious now how many
quarterbacks in the NFL during the Brees
adopted Drew Brees his routine from his
backup quarterbacks have come out I want
this to come out to remember like
someone tried to do the rock like his
training schedule for our wahlburgers
yeah yeah yeah all that stuff I kind of
want to see how long I could last doing
Drew Brees because it might be like
until noon on day one like you know what
I'm tapping out I'm like you know what
I'm only smoking daddy cigars on
Wednesday I'm screwed yeah okay this is
the number but listen that's another
little piece of ammunition that makes me
think
Taysom Hill you know 2020 face of the
franchise I like it but the thing is
Taysom Hill and Drew Brees could not be
more different in terms of the type of
player they are so maybe that's not a
good thing to do the exact same routine
uh well I mean but oh but Drew Brees is
a monster in the gym oh for sure and
Hayes Mills
monster in a gym I just thinking like
should they be eating different diets
should they be working with different
kinds of trainers should you know like I
don't know what she's a little
exaggerated yeah you think well that's
why it's a what we're allowed to blow it
up what would be the weirdest thing that
he would copy I would go drew brees be
like please stop I don't know like if he
calls true breezes wife yeah Taysom Hill
just drives home to Drew's house at the
end of the night he's like alright good
night honey way the bit ends is true
breezes in bed and he's like and he
rolls over and he kisses his wife and
then he rolls over and he kisses Taysom
Hill and then it's like Jimmy Kimmel
back on so it's darkness than you here
good night true
good night tase him and then yeah that's
the end of the PA someone blows out a
candle because it's 1850s is that
episode 8 of to the plate yeah let's
taste them on the show next year okay
ready for number one yes oh hold on oh
sorry ingress hammer yes I forgetting
burrs that's good that's a good enough
drought right there this one is not from
any specific publication it's actually
been on every publication oh just what
makes it a whoa I feel like every single
website that I've visited has some
version of the dolphins are interested
in trading for Jadeveon Clowney yes
right that is such an off seasoning
story there's no verification there's no
it's going to happen there's just this
general floating thing in the air that
the Dolphins who are an NFL team are
interested in acquiring Jadeveon Clowney
who's a very good NFL player and
apparently they've met yeah sure no they
were able to discuss things with each
other that jenavian has to ask for
permission to talk with certain teams
the [ __ ] is that I've never heard of a
coach and a player talking that aren't
on the anyway if for sure but for me
just when I see this because it happens
in all sports where it's just like hey
this team is interested in acquiring
this good player I just think and
January furnishing your brain and it
feels like he's already on the team well
I just think On January 1st we should
just have a blanket news statement that
says every team is interested in
acquiring every good player if they can
make the assets work and that we don't
have to have these dumb rumor things if
Jadeveon Clowney signs an offer sheet
for the Dolphins that's news yes but the
fact that the Dolphins are interested in
signing a very good player should not be
leading the front page of every sports
story it's also making me think right
now and I really need to look this up
quickly
so the story was originally Jadeveon
Clowney has fired his agent bus cook who
he's had for a long time because he was
frustrated at the the negotiation
tactics that have been used the last
couple right and my thing to do Davey
would go maybe it's not going great
because the Texans don't have a general
[ __ ] manager right now yeah no one's
talked about the fact that like maybe
the issue isn't Jadeveon Clowney maybe
it's a fact that there's four guys in
the front office of the Texans that are
all like it's succession right now I'm
in the front office of the Texan so he's
the chef and he's the Roman guys walking
around being like oh no no no I'm
totally cool with sharing the power and
then going to one person be like you
tell me anything that he says when I
leave this room so maybe that's the
reason Jadeveon Clowney is not getting a
deal right now apparently he is more
interested in joining the Eagles and the
Seahawks this is the I don't know
eighteenth a rumor that's already
surfaced from Miami which makes me worry
for Brian Flores that the leaks are
aplenty in Miami but we've heard out of
Miami the last two weeks is Brian Flores
played eight jay-z songs for Kenny
Stills the Dolphins are interested in
trading Laremy Tunsil the Dolphins are
probably gonna cut Kenny Stills any
single time one of these quarterbacks
have breathed we've known Josh Rosen's
moved up he's moved down there are so
many leaks in Miami right now that I'm
starting to worry about Brian Flores
completely unrelated to that but let's
say it gets down to those three teams
the reason this notebook helps is I
realize the issues for some of these
teams I look at the Eagles and I go they
are expecting other than Brandon Graham
very consistent pass rush from Josh
sweat Derek Barnett and Vinny curry I am
not a hundred percent guaranteed that
those guys can hold up the whole season
if you really think you can win the
Super Bowl I look at the Seahawks a my
issue with the Seahawks
Juran Reed suspended for the first six
weeks of the season people seem to
forget that LJ Collier their first-round
pick had a uniquely sprained ankle and
they don't know what's going on and
Ansah has had a groin injury so here's a
Seahawks team that there's their
depleted right now up front and the
Dolphins just stink everywhere I just
enjoy watching you go through a notebook
as opposed to googling things furiously
it's this is very like 1960s journalists
like you should be chomping on an actual
cigar not a daddy cigar just like a and
the newsroom mail and check out my notes
here exactly so the question that I have
for all of them too is what who is it
more necessary to and who has the
ammunition to give up the reason this
fits the Eagles really well is it's very
Eagles to make a trade for a player and
then let him go and then get a
third-round comp pick in reward for him
but I think jenavian is only playing if
he gets a contract and because the
Seahawks I'm gonna bet that he ends up
in Seattle because also who made a trade
last year Seattle and Houston Seattle
traded to get Dwane Brown the starting
left tackle that they got from Houston
so there is a connection I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that he goes to Seattle but
Miami wanting him has been everywhere
I'm just I'm worried about Miami right
now they have they have leak City
intermit like the coach of the Patriots
won't even admit that he knew that
Andrew Luck retired and in Miami I know
at what Brian Flores is I Tunes look
like that's the difference between those
two franchises right do you think that
it's time to transition into the AFC
East then if we're talking about Miami
and the possible basement alright so
here's the deal I'm gonna be doing this
live I have picked my six playoff teams
but I also might change them at any time
can I give three little nuggets before
we start going absolutely three of the
things that I focused on the most are
going to be these strengths of schedule
second-year quarterbacks and one score
games these are Nuggets that I have just
looked over time and and things that are
trends the way that I'm picking my teams
this year in addition to looking at the
depth charts and looking at you know
who's got
I really value the too deep at defensive
line and linebacker because those are
the guys that get hurt and the deeper
you are in the beginning of the season
the more they last but a lot of these
statistics it's like a 16 in blackjack
okay if you were really good at
turnovers last year and in in blackjack
a lot of face cards have been out there
then in your head you've been counting
cards
here come the low cards so if you got a
lot of turnovers last year the smart bet
is that you're not going to get a lot
next year if you want a lot of one score
games last year history has shown that
that regresses to the mean the next year
so what I'm saying is not guaranteed but
in all good bets with analytics you have
to bet the reverse on that would you
agree yeah that sounds right
my I know this is your wheelhouse I love
living in this universe I also want to
talk about the pics that you're about to
make are the pics of what you think is
about to happen not gambling value right
so I'll give some gambling and that's
totally fine I just want before we get
get into the thick of it I want to
explain what plus and minus means what
we're talking about the lines here so
for example looking at the AFC East the
New England Patriots are minus 500 which
means you'd have to bet $500 in order to
win a measly $100 right so even if you
think it's a very good chance the
Patriots are gonna win the AFC East it's
probably not a good gamble but it's a
good pick exactly if you're just saying
that's what's going to happen whereas
the New York Jets are plus 600 which
means if you bet $100 that's pretty
tasty
you win 600 that's what I'm saying so
that might not be your pick to win the
AFC but the idea of what would you be
willing to put money down on it's a very
different thing so I just throwing that
out there for the folks out there that
are not well versed in gambling parlance
so the strength of schedule amusing is
from Warren sharps book and he does it
based on Vegas predicted win-loss total
the reason is that's the strength of
schedule that has been seen to be the
most accurate surprise surprise Vegas is
really good at picking who goes further
in the playoffs so last year the top 10
teams that had the softest schedule five
of them made the playoffs last year the
top ten teams that had the hardest
schedule one team made the play
it was the Chiefs so there is some
recency bias that it is accurate
here are the easiest schedules in the
league in terms of strength of schedule
the easiest schedule in the league is
the Patriots which is incredible it's
somehow happens every year it's amazing
you guys were second easiest last year
I'm gonna go this is from easiest to the
10th easiest Patriots Jets Eagles Browns
Bills Giants Rams Chargers Colts Cowboys
- that's the 10 easiest schedules
easiest from easiest to 10th easiest I'm
just you can replay it if you want
hardest hardest in the NFL is Houston
they had the easiest last year today
went from worst to first
they went from easiest schedule in the
NFL to hardest schedule in the NFL I'm
factoring that into my picks something
we'll get to later but sec so hardest is
Houston second hardest is Denver third
hardest is Oakland then Tennessee
Chicago Atlanta Miami Kansas City again
Tampa and Arizona so here's what I did
the teams that are in the hardest that
people are definitely having maybe in
the playoff conversation Chicago Atlanta
Kansas City last year only one team made
it mm-hmm that's those are three good
teams right there but the playoff teams
in the easiest Patriots Jets Eagles
Browns Rams Chargers Cowboys it's a
murderer's row right now of teams that
have an easy schedule and if they had
the Colts on their schedule it got
easier - yeah that just sort of like
upgraded from a b-plus difficulty to a B
- so just think about that when you're
making your own picks of those lists
second thing I want to talk about with
second-year quarterbacks taken in the
top 15 of their drafts in their first
year they have a winning record of 39
percent in the last seven years that's
what it's been in the last seven years
their second year the winning percentage
goes from 39 to 63 I talked about this a
few weeks ago but I factored into my
picks the teams that I circled then
Bill's Jets Ravens Browns okay the
crossover between the two lists and this
is going to completely impact my own
rankings Buffalo and Cleveland have the
Cleveland and Buffalo have the fourth
and fifth easiest schedules and they've
got quarterbacks man they had
quarterbacks going into their year too
and I don't know if all my list I have
them in the playoffs interesting so you
might be going against your own wisdom
here yeah I might have that's fine
that's is why we're that's why we're
sussing it out sometimes you need a
notebook sometimes I need my interesting
nugget that's an interesting nugget they
cross off two of those and I'll tell you
what if things go south with my new
england patriots and maybe the Jets
don't live up to expectations the
Buffalo Bills are at plus nine fifty
nine and a half to one odds to win the
division maybe all you need is ten wins
this year to get there are fifty bucks
on the Jets and the bills I'm not upset
that's what I'm saying no that's a
that's a value-add if you a very big
money win if you put 50 bucks on the
Jets to win 350 bucks on the Buffalo
Bills to win 475 now this one is very
big to me one score game results so
games in which a team wins in one
possession seven or less the reason is
because this historically it's been
insanely predictive so since 1989 12
teams have gone six and one in one score
games the following year those same
teams combined for a record of 39 and 45
in those same games they basically
regressed to a 500 winning percentage
which is essentially what you should
expect to have exactly one score games
yes so the average win decline for those
teams was almost for the next season so
it's a very big deal in the same time
period 27 teams won five more one score
games than they lost so this is now it's
not just 601 now it could be seven and
200 or they won 82% of those games in
that year the next year they won 45% of
them again regression to about that
which is what you should expect there
are four teams that are apparently
looking at a negative regression this
year
okay let me just I'm gonna try and
individually pull them up so I can give
you the exact number one of those teams
is the Rams the Rams were six and one in
one score game call in a Super Bowl Rams
frauds I'm not saying that I'm giving
the information that's true I'm liking
your information knocked me over the
Chargers six and one and one score games
last year okay these are teams that
people are gonna bet on a team that I am
predicting right now will be the worst
team in the NFL because when I get to
them their analytics are wild the
Dolphins were seven and one in one score
games last she totally unsustainable in
what was gonna say since 1995 teams that
were seven and one in one score games
all of them won more than ten games the
Dolphins went seven and nine so only
wins the winds were that and then the
next year all those other teams went
down to like 500 in their complete
winning percentage so what the hell's
got to happen to the Dolphins mm-hmm the
other team and this is a historical
historical one score was the Cowboys the
Cowboys were nine and three in one score
games so nine of their wins were in one
score games and they went ten and six
right so nine other other ten or eleven
wins whatever it was he should there
were ten and six oh yeah nine of their
10 wins were one score one score games
and a six-game margin so I did also
shows that twelve of their 16 games were
within one score that there was just
like no blowouts in either direction
it's incredible to look at their play
calling and we'll get to the NFC East
but I'm just saying the four teams that
are supposed to have regression in the
one score games Cowboys Rams dolphins
Chargers Cowboys Rams and chargers I
mean those are Super Bowl contenders you
go to Super Bowl odds right now I mean
they're all looking good
so it's it's I just found that very
interesting yeah you're given the
information people can do with it what
they will like the Giants
eight in one score games that should
probably regress the other way
Packers three and six in one score games
that's a kind of team where I'm looking
at a positive regression you kind of go
through lions two and four three and
seven for the Panthers you know so it's
both ways but this has been more
predictive the teams that won more
coming back because sometimes bad teams
are just bad
now do you buy that a team that
consistently wins one score games it
could be because they have that clutch
thing so Peyton Manning was a genius at
winning close game so we're getting to
the AFC East right now we're gonna start
going through Adam GaSe with Miami in
his first three years he went twenty and
six in one score game that's unreal so
part of me wants to give that to Adam
GaSe and then part of me wants to pump
that up with the Jets you know and I
mean cuz it's like maybe he's just a
really good coach and one score game
he's great in the final five minutes you
know calling timeouts at the right time
calling the right plays being able to
play the prevent properly all that stuff
yeah all right so let's get to the AFC
let's get into the AFC East first
question I'm gonna ask you at the start
of every division is who's gonna win and
how many playoff teams are coming out of
this division I see two playoff teams
okay have seized I'm gonna say that my
predicted team for last place is the
Miami Dolphins let me give you the
laundry list of reasons their strength
of schedule is 26 the NFL and it went
down 22 spots compared to last year
strength of schedule
brutal yeah that's why they were able to
win those seven games because they the
fourth easiest schedule so they went
from four to 26 they were positive five
turnovers last year and that will likely
regress to the mean as well seven and
one in one score games this year they
face the second hardest defenses overall
they face the hardest past defenses in
the NFL according to last year
statistics and they're doing it with
Ryan Fitzpatrick and Josh Rosen week
seven through nine they faced three
teams on extra rest and they spent the
least amount of money on their offensive
line compared to any team in the NFL I
look at the Dolphins as your worst team
in the
last year the team that I don't have
making it because you know that I have
the Patriots making it I don't have the
bills in the playoffs okay and I just
talked about the bills being the easy
schedule plus the second year
improvement they have an incredible they
have the fifth best strength of schedule
in the NFL in terms of easy
they were minus five and turnovers so
they should go more turnovers next year
by the way there is no statistic more
indicative of wins the NFL than
turnovers if I beat you in the turnover
margin I have an 80% chance of winning
the game and it's just it's the number
one sense you and you earn yourself two
or three extra possessions a game the
Buffalo Bills the reason it's really
hard for me to be a big bet against them
is they face the sixth easiest offenses
in the NFL so their defense should be a
lot better and their offense faces the
second easiest run defenses through week
11 and I just think about Sean McDermott
and Josh Allen they're gonna want to run
the ball I think the bills are a team
that they're over/under is seven I like
them as an eight win team I think that
they're right around there and if they
proved me wrong they're going 9 the team
that I have as a wild-card team not when
the division is the New York Jets I got
really excited for a moment you're gonna
get a little unlucky the Jets have the
second easiest schedule in the NFL it
was 10th easiest last year so what up
8th which is a big deal
they had -10 in turnovers last year
amazing positive regression two and six
and one score games and then you have
Adam gates who I talked about before
coming in with twenty and six the last
two years weeks one through eight so the
only thing is they're the only team in
the NFL that play five bottom five teams
and eight bottom ten teams and they have
an early buy and they get the the
Patriots twice in the first seven games
which what I talked about before is when
you want to play the Patriots yeah
they're not rounding into January form
yet this is going to be my sign though
on whether I'm right we will know in the
first eight weeks if the Jets are making
the playoffs and this is
weeks 9 through 17 they face the 11th
easiest pass defenses in the NFL I think
that the second half of the year the
Jets are gonna make a run but weeks one
through eight they play the second
toughest pass defenses in the NFL weeks
one through eight that Jets play the
Browns the Eagles the Cowboys and the
Patriots twice if in my mind that Jets
start off four and four they're gonna
finish with ten wins mmm that's my
prediction for the Jets so I'm gonna
write that down
where if they start off fast watch out
and if they start off slow man they're
gonna be fighting for a spot but I think
they can make a late run but if they can
go four and four I feel really good the
things that concern me obviously they
lose Avery Williamson to a torn ACL
according to Brandon thorns offensive
line rankings he has them at 28th I'm
higher on Collette Co Semele than others
my big fear picking this [ __ ] team is
that Ryan Khalil as their starting
center and he was retired like three
weeks ago and so I'm putting a lot of
hope into this offensive line and the
Patriots I'm having win the East they
have the easiest schedule in terms of
strength of schedule in the NFL second
easiest opponents offensive and passing
offense and I just go Bill Belichick
who's gonna eat those alive mm-hmm
now the teams that I let out I've
already kind of gone into the bills I'm
just gonna actually you don't know who
I'm leaving out cuz I still have one
more wildcard team that's right so I
have the Patriots winning and the Jets
as a wild-card team okay the reason and
I'll just wrap it up I know I'm going
too long but this is a wild-card
division what came down to the reason I
picked the Jets over the bills is I did
not see playmakers in the bills roster
when they need it I like John Brown I
like LeSean McCoy and Frank Gore and
Devin Singletary and Zay Jones and Cole
Beasley and Tyler Croft but there's no
one there that's winning on one on one
there's no one so when push comes to
shove where is the playmaker other than
your quarterback for the Jets
I got levee on bail I got Robbie
Anderson
getting Chris Herndon back halfway
through the year after of the fourth
week I like Jameson Crowder I like the
pieces more and really I think levian is
gonna be a baller this year and so for
me it came down to who has the the
winners and then I looked at the Jets
and I looked at their safeties in May
and Adams and I looked at Quintin
Williams and Leonard Williams and went
they're gonna control the line of
scrimmage
but Le'Veon Bell pushed that team over
the bills for me you know also as you're
talking about second-year quarterbacks
giving Sam Darnell the ultimate safety
blanket and I have a lot more faith in
Sam Darnell than Josh Allen I think Josh
Allen would be really good this year I
think Sam dard old jumps up into the top
12 quarterbacks in the NFL maybe top 10
I just think with with with darn old you
know little more poise you know second
year and he's always got Le'Veon Bell
may be the best catcher out of the flats
that we've seen in years some case
there's a guy that can make his offense
easier for him indeed okay all right
moving on to the AFC North you ready for
the AFC North ado you want to do a
different okay how many playoff teams
are coming out of the AFC North - whoa
okay no that means like the Chargers are
out that means they'll know that you
don't know why picked for the West that
is true I feel like that you're gonna
choose the okay on the Bronco Cleveland
Browns Pittsburgh Steelers Baltimore
Ravens Cincinnati Bengals in order in
terms of their Vegas rankings right now
who do you have winning the division
Cleveland is at plus 115 so you have to
bet a hundred hours to win 115
essentially 5050 odds
pittsburgh's at plus 190 so you get kind
of two-to-one odds Baltimore Ravens at
plus 300 and then Bengals at plus 1600
essentially like a miracle would have to
happen give them to me one more time
plus 115 yeah for the Browns lost
favorite oh for sure okay bye a lot and
this is as of today Wow plus 190
Pittsburgh Steelers okay and then plus
300 for the Baltimore Ravens which are
I'm just gonna I'm gonna jump right out
I have the Ravens winning this division
and I would bet on plus 300 that they're
winning the division yeah you get a nice
little payout so that's one of the
playoff teams the team that I have
coming in last let's not spend a lot of
time on them isn't since any
ingles guess who plays the toughest past
defenses in the NFL this year and
doesn't have AJ green and their
first-round pick Billy price isn't even
playing right now and their offensive
lines a mess
the Bengals oh I was gonna guess that
the Ravens oh sorry the six of their
first nine weeks are against top five
past defenses from last year the Bengals
could start off really bad Bengals and
dolphins are fighting for the first pick
in the draft but they were two and five
and one score games looking forward to a
lot of like nine six five three type of
first half scores no the the Bengals the
Bengals are gonna be the oh you know you
might be right they will be the low
scoring team the Niners are the team
that you should bet the over every game
the Niners defense stinks and it's
another story but bet the over early on
the Niners share at the first five weeks
okay so let me do the Ravens winning and
then I'll tell you who makes the
playoffs and who doesn't out of Steelers
and Browns I have the Ravens winning
because when I did my plus and minuses
they were a plus on almost every single
thing they lost hey Vaughn young the
cornerback but literally their secondary
in my mind is the deepest secondary in
the NFL Marlin Humphrey Jimmy Smith
Brandon Carr Cyrus Jones Earl Thomas
Tony Jefferson they're gonna be amazing
there are two deep defensive line and
their linebackers my only concern about
the Ravens is where are they getting
their sacks from but they're also one of
those teams that has like 14 guys that
they're just gonna rotate so they're
gonna be fresh and that they'll figure
it out like a hockey team the thing that
excites me the most 12th in terms of
strength of schedule and it went in
improved by 11 compared to last year
double-digit change one of the biggest
in the NFL they were minus three and
turnovers I don't see that happening
again three and four and one score games
there's a positive regression there they
face the second easiest run defenses in
the NFL and what have the Ravens spent
all offseason preparing for to Zig when
everyone else zags and to run when
everyone else is throwing so not only
have they loaded up on their offensive
line signed Mark Ingram drafted just as
he'll have Gus Edwards have Lamar
Jackson have four tight ends that can
all block and
have a fullback I don't think people
talk about this enough their fullback as
Patrick Ricard who also plays defensive
tackle this is a team that is going to
run all year and they face the second
easiest run defenses for the season it's
a reason I drafted just as Hill and like
the 11th round of all my fantasy drafts
they don't have to play Pittsburgh in
primetime which historically has been an
issue in the past though after the bye
they faced New England so they have
extra rest to face than the one time
they play New England and listen to this
step in the last few years when they
faced quarterbacks who are in years one
and two they have an eight and four
record because that's just wink
Martindale scheming up for young
quarterbacks that have not seen anything
the Ravens play a defense that other
teams are not used to facing they face
six quarterbacks this season either in
year one or year two I look at the
Ravens they're deep across the board
they're fundamentally sound they have
the best kicker in the NFL they this
punter in the NFL all of the statistics
suggest positive regressions and I love
their coach and I think their
quarterback is going into what year year
two Ravens are going to not just be my
AFC North predicting team to win they're
also going to be my number one seed in
the AFC Wow number one seed over on
seeing the AFC
14 wins their time they were one of my
preseason left collogues and I bet with
crack so that means I also have the
Sharps on my side how what did you think
of all that there's a lot yeah you've
done your homework and the thing is like
I could my best that's right you're
gonna put them up yeah well I got put
them up eventually we'll pin them all
over the wall here so that you know that
these are real is putting his money
where his mouth is yeah I got the Ravens
right here
I bet 162 win 128 that they will go over
eight so you just heard everything I'm
saying
the Ravens are plus 300 to win the
division if you like them to be the
number one seed their line isn't there
line is now now I checked that yesterday
the lines actually up to 8 and a half
this Jesus mate so just saying very how
the Ravens now to the team that I'm
putting in as a wild-card
the Browns are missing the playoffs oh
yes that was like this is killing me
the Browns had the fourth easiest
schedule in the NFL they had the biggest
jump from hard schedule to easy schedule
in the NFL 26 spots so the Texans go
from easiest to worst the Browns are the
biggest jump from worse to easiest they
were plus seven and turnovers last year
which is not great they were five and
four one score games which is whatever
but they are also having the toughest
jump in past defenses faced and the
reason that I'm leaving the Browns out
over the Steelers is because I'm worried
about the Browns offensive line Baker
Mayfield looks amazing
Odell Beckham and Jarvis Landry are
gonna be great Nicholas Chubb is gonna
be a top five fantasy guy and Kareem
hunts gonna come in week ten and they're
gonna look great but my issue with the
Browns is their offensive line 27th in
the NFL according to Brandon Thorne's
offensive line projections he's with
establish the run calm and I watched
that Bucs preseason game and Baker
Mayfield was running for his life a lot
and you have a first-year head coach
who's also gonna be the OC with Todd
Monken
and I just I think the offensive line is
gonna want a good what's gonna prevent
them and so I look at the Browns and I
just I think frustration early in the
year Baker Odell because they're not
gonna have the time to get these plays
off in the back their defense though if
you're drafting and you need a fantasy
defense Browns defense faces the third
this the last year they face the third
toughest this year 20 second toughest
they're gonna have a great year but I'm
going with the Steelers the Steelers
offensive line fourth in the NFL
according to Brandon thorns offensive
line rankings they were 29 for the NFL
in terms of strength of schedule it's
all the way up to 13th so they had a
huge jump to their turnover ratio last
year was minus 11 and they faced the
fifth easiest run defense in the entire
NFL I look at the Steelers and the
reason that I had them in
is the offensive line Villanueva foster
Pouncy de castro feeler I think is
phenomenal I look at their defense and I
see Heyward Hargrave to it with no
injuries this year they've added Devin
Busch in the first round with Mark Baron
people forget he's on that team you got
blood Dupree TJ Watt chicle oh I'm a
little bit concerned with Joe Hayden's
injury and Shawn Davis's injury in the
preseason but I look at the Steelers I
think Ben Roethlisberger is a big year I
think this team with the loss of their
wide receiver coach and Antonio Brown
talking all this [ __ ] and Le'Veon Bell
talking all this [ __ ] I think that
people are gonna sleep on the Steelers
and they come and they get that
wild-card spot
I respect the pick of course you know
the Cleveland Browns could come out of
nowhere and like live up to the hype I
don't just you know the Bengals coming
out of nowhere but my wild card battles
for that last spot where Jets Bills
Browns and then I'll let you know who
else in the south and the West
I'll make these quick or those took a
little bit too long now we're into the
AFC South which of course has been
thrown into some turmoil over the last
couple weeks I think a lot of people
have the Colts penciled in for that now
they're down they're down to the worst
odds in the AFC AFC over/under now seven
and a half that sounds about right i
mean Jacoby reset go prove the haters
wrong my friend I'll be quick about the
Colts I have them about eight wins which
I think you know they might start out
really fast but I do not have them make
in the playoffs
I'm sorry to jump no they're at plus 450
to win the division so pretty long odds
I will be honest though it's not a bad
bet yeah no one in the south is a lock
right so plus 450 for a team that Andrew
Luck was probably worth two to three
wins but if you had them as a 12 win
team they could still win the division
at ten yeah so not a bad bet a lot of
respect for nick foles here because i
would have thought that texans would
have would be a lot heavier favorite
yeah to win this division they're plus
175 whereas the jaguars are plus 225 so
pretty similar pretty similar odds for
Texans and jaguars Tennessee Titans at
plus 300 we don't know what's going on
there Tannehill yep and Mariota and then
the Colts are at plus 450 currently in
the basement of that decision so
obviously I have one team if I was if I
had a
50 dollars and I wanted to bet on
season-long stuff and I haven't bet it
yet I already have my seasonal and I
don't want to wait five more months for
more money I would throw $50 on the
Colts to win the division because at 450
you're just getting too good of odds for
a team that's I think head to toe
probably better than every other team of
the division other than quarterback but
I would throw $100 on my tino in the
division which is the jaguars okay so
you'd have $100 to win to 25 and $50 to
win to 25 from the Indianapolis great so
150 to hopefully 150 to guarantee
yourself an extra 75 bucks plus 220 yeah
that sounds right those good odds I
don't love it because I think the Texans
are better right so let me tell you why
they're not the team that I expect to
come in last place is the Tennessee
Titans
I think the Titans are about to have a
very very awful year this is the team
that's been hanging around eight wins
the last few years if they miracle II
get into the wild-card great if they
don't they say it's because mario 2 got
hurt their strength of schedule is 29th
they went 10 down last year there are
four and three and one score games this
is Mario does forth new offensive
coordinator in the last five years and
last year they faced the sixth softest
offenses in the NFL these are the
quarterbacks of the Titans faced last
year with Frei Bulls defense
Josh Allen rookie Eli Josh Johnson came
in from injury McCown didn't finish the
year bortles Joe Flacco Cody Kessler and
Ryan Tannehill now instead of bortles
they play foals twice a year they also
have to go up against this year
mahomes Baker Brees rivers and Ryan when
you add to the fact that their offensive
line was already not great and they
don't have Taylor LaJuan for the first
four weeks and Marcus Mariota had the
hand issue and Ryan Tannehill snot that
solid I think that the Tennessee Titans
show that they were gonna have a season
to forget when they drafted Jeremy
Simmons with wood excuse me Jeffrey
Simmons with our first pick who has an
ACL injury this is a throwaway year for
the Titans I think they come in last
the reason I'm not high on the Texans no
one had a harder drop-off remember in
strength of schedule than the Houston
Texans they went from first to 32nd so
that's part of the reason I'm picking
against him then you add in the fact
that in turnovers they were plus 13 last
year one of the most in the NFL so they
had an amazing schedule they had a ton
of turnovers they were six and five and
one score games they faced the third
toughest offense and the fifth toughest
past offense and last time I checked
Jadeveon Clowney is not coming back when
you also figure out that the Texans are
one of the worst adjusted football teams
at half time under bail O'Brien in the
last two years when the Texans have been
tied at half time were losing they've
played 17 games what do you think their
record was in those games
oh god six and 11 one in sixth brother
so when Bill O'Brien is tied at halftime
or losing call your bookie and bit money
line the other way cuz it's over well
maybe that's exactly what he wants you
to think he's been season playing some
crazy chess matches does that [ __ ] me
this just this year now he's gonna start
doing some adjustments there our 31st
and Brandon thorns offensive line
rankings I will say that having watched
in pre-season titus Howard and Mack
scharping their first two picks have
looked really good at guard but they've
got Matt Khalil who's got an injury
there just injured everywhere they just
lost the loriel or ACL but I will say
that I do think DeSean Watson has a good
year they face the 11th softest past
defenses and because I think their
defense takes a huge step back I think
their offense is having to put up a lot
of points so fuller Hopkins I think it's
a good fantasy team but I think the
Texans are a 5 6 win team I have the
Jaguars winning the south from a number
of reasons they have the 21st easiest
strength of schedule I don't like that
tell them Smith is out this year I don't
like that he's taken a personal year
the Jacksonville Jaguars last year and
their turnovers david Ingeborg -12 the
Jaguars
why wasn't cuz their defense wasn't
getting turnovers who was their
quarterback Blake Blake bortles and Cody
Kessler I think that Turk listen to this
this is crazy their turnover margin went
from like plus 15 to minus 12 their sack
margin in 2017
was plus 31 last year it was minus 16 it
was the greatest drop-off in sacks in
the last 30 years we're regressing to
the mean Josh Allen coleus Campbell
Marcell Darius Yannick and Gok way
Avery Jones Haven Brian day tone Jones
that group was - 16 in sacks and the
reason is their quarterbacks kept
putting them in holes and teams were
running on them so they didn't get the
opportunities for sex nick foles ain't
doing that this year
the offensive line I think is going to
improve greatly they've invested a lot
of pics chauhan Taylor I think Ken
Robinson comes back from injury Leonard
fournette looks really healthy I am
buying Nick Foles I am buy for other
five offensive lineman last year went on
I are everything to me looks like
they're regressing to the mean this is a
team that people had as a Super Bowl
contender last year and they fell off
the face of the earth because their
quarterback situation in injuries
Jaguars win the cell I respect the pic I
just want the people out there listening
it's possible this is your first time
listening to a podcast because NFL
seasons coming around and just wanted to
listen to a preview yeah this is just my
takes left go is an unabashedly gel's
fan that will love Nick Foles with the
with the passion that I love Tom Brady
is a Patriots fan I'm just throwing it
out there I know you have the ability to
be unbiased I just want the people to
know because I think you've talked about
being an Eagles fan yet on this podcast
today I mean [ __ ] but you know I want
you I am saying this definitively I want
you to know that betting on the NFL is
like hitting on 16 in blackjack you're
supposed to but it's probably not going
to end
I don't know if that's good or not but
oh I'm gonna be completely wrong on some
of these some of them I feel very
confident will keep track of this I mean
look I'm gonna I'm gonna pretend like
you put let's say $100 out on each one
of these these division winner picks
we'll see how you did at the end of your
maybe your net positive would be great
okay now see you guys to the AFC West
we've got the Kansas City Chiefs want to
guess the line for elector over/under no
to it to win the division what's there -
50 that's exactly it
Wow very impressive nice win followed by
the Los Angeles chargers 125 plus 190
okay uh-huh
then the Oakland Raiders plus 1,100 the
Broncos plus 1200 so it's essentially a
two horse race yes it is I'm not sure
what order these two are gonna finish in
here are the reasons why I don't think
the Raiders and the Broncos are making
the playoffs Raiders offensive line is
really not that good right now Gabe
Jackson tore his MCL two weeks ago so
when they're best guards is out for six
weeks and let's just say they were
already thin at the position strength of
schedule for the Raiders 30th Tom cable
as their offensive line coach their
defense is facing the sixth toughest
offense schedule and their offense is
facing the fourth toughest defensive
schedule but none of that matters
because they have hundred Renfro hundred
Renfro they love that guy that's the
only thing that really matters on this
team there's only 16 games
I think the Raiders are gonna be an up
and down team I am gonna try to avoid
betting them on them all year because I
just don't know what's gonna happen with
them the Broncos have the 31st toughest
schedule that the 31st easiest Zowie
second toughest schedule in the NFL
their plus seven and turnovers last year
they face the seventh toughest defenses
and the ninth toughest run defenses I
have no faith in this offense this year
Rick scangarelo is the offensive
coordinator that Shanahan scheme I just
look at that team Emanuel Sanders is
coming off an Achilles I don't I don't
know about Phillip Lindsey I don't have
any trust in Joe Flacco and that
offensive line has a rookie at left
guard and the right guard Ron O'Leary is
coming off of an Achilles and their
Center Connor McGovern
not that good so when I look at this
team it's gonna be a have to be a lot of
defense and I think Vic Fangio is gonna
maybe start off quick the only thing
that hurt me by the way I looked it up
they play the bears at home and that
revenge game remember the Bears play
Thursday Night Football to start the
season so they have 10 days rest to
acclimate to the Denver altitude and so
I'm gonna pull back what I said the
other day so between the Chiefs and the
Chargers I have the Chiefs winning the
division ok the reason and I have a lot
of negatives for these teams but I'll
start with the Chargers I I just am
betting that Melvin Gordon doesn't play
this year I just of all the monetary
situations I have never heard one peep
of the Chargers and/or Melvin Gordon
feel good right now and I don't think
that Eckler and Justin Jackson are solid
enough guys this Derwin James injury is
serious he had a foot fracture and
thanks to my guy pro football doc who
really has been a resource for me
predicting games this year he has a foot
fracture in the same bone that he had in
2016 and it's a bended screw and this is
the pro football doc used to work for
the Chargers so he's got an insight
there it looks like if during James does
return it's at the end of the year this
is like kam chancellor missing the
Seahawks back when they had their run
it's that big of a loss in my mind also
Russell o Kuhn has blood clots in his
lungs and they are already a rough
offensive line with we don't know
working at a forest lamp and Sam Teddy
and Schofield so I saw Phillip Rivers
arms start to decline last year and now
the offensive lines not going to be that
good and Melvin Gordon's not going to be
there and Keenan Allen's kind of banged
up again so my other issues were six and
one in one score games which I said
earlier huge regression capabilities
they did have a lot of injuries last
year and you would expect that to get
more normal but the problem is is the
Chargers and they're in
every single year it's a medical staff
the Chargers don't have an analytics
department they don't have an advanced
medical staff sometimes you just don't
have good facilities they have the
cheapest owner in the NFL he's not
paying for the move like there's just a
cheap organization that played in the
dump for a very long time and continue
to play in a dump so my only thing
that's positive is they're two games in
Florida this year or later in the year
you never want to play Miami and Tampa
in the beginning when it's like
swamp-ass at 94 degrees and there are
two games against the Chiefs one of them
is in Mexico and they have nine days
rest compared to the Chiefs who have six
days rest that's huge because that's
altitude as well absolutely and the
other time is week 17 where if the
Chargers are fighting for a playoff spot
the Chiefs will likely rest all their
starters so just something to think
about then but the reason I'm going with
the Chiefs is I just think there are a
great football team sometimes that's
what it comes down to patrick mahomes
Damian Williams is healthy I love this
kid Darwin Thompson I've drafted him on
both of my fantasy teams as a third
running back guy Tyree kills Sammy
Watkins is healthy Michael Harmon
DeMarcus Robinson Travis Kelce is
healthy their offensive line is solid
and I think that their defense with
Chris Jones Frank Clark Derek Nadi Alex
Okafor Emmanuel augment they got some
speed at linebacker at Darren Lee who I
think needed a change of pace and their
cornerbacks tire and Mathew coming in at
safety is huge here are the scary things
for the Chiefs 25th and script strength
of schedule plus 9 and turnovers last
year they had insane sack production but
I think that continues again because I
think the Chiefs jump out to early leads
allowing them to get more sacks they
face the toughest run defenses in the
NFL this year so Damian William Byers
kind of slow your roll that's why I like
Darwin Thompson because you're gonna
throw more do your running backs then
run it I just think the Chiefs are the
team I I will say that Patrick mahomes
scares the daylights out of any
defensive coordinator and that you might
be a great defensive run stopper and you
show up in Kansas City and home I got
you spread everybody out and you got
five D
B's back there like you might not be the
vaunted defensive run ski run stopping
scheme that you thought you were a week
earlier alright so let's look at the the
six top six C's in the AFC you had
Ravens at number one can I tell can you
tell that I've like been thinking about
this for a long time yes you're pouring
so many slows names and schemes at me I
don't even know how to keep I've been
going to bed before 2 in the last week
respect I go to bed around 9:30 p.m.
wake up at 5 so we're getting the same
amount of sleep I thought yeah
Ravens number one seed you said they are
Patriots or Chiefs number two or three
Patriots two Patriots too they get a buy
it seems like every year for like nine
years now the Chiefs then I think the
Chiefs at two and then I flip them
because I was like the Patriots are
gonna somehow gonna buy cheese feel like
quote unquote a regression team but
still damn good right they might not go
forward an entombed they might be a
really good 11 in 5 10 and 16 yeah so
Chiefs three seed then that would leave
the Jags as the four seed huh and then
Jets five Steelers six type of things
healers five Jets second switch him up
here so the teams that barely missed the
Browns I didn't put them in because
their offensive line and I know that
seems kind of crazy because the Jets
have an offensive line issue too but
really that's an issue for every team
that I left out so the teams that I left
out that were close to me were the bills
Browns chargers and Colts bills brows
and chargers all have offensive lines
that scare me the Colts do not I just
think that they're missing the
quarterback to get it done and all their
wide receivers are hurt right now and it
just they're a really good team that
just misses the playoffs yeah but if
they knocked out the jet if if that if
the Colts chargers or Browns or bills
got the succeed instead of the Jets I
would completely understand it I just
think that the Steelers are definitely
the fifth seed in the wild all right I
like it so now we're looking at wildcard
weekend it's gonna be Steelers at Jags
so we'll do the AFC and then we'll do
the NFC exactly Steelers at Jags would
probably be that like Saturday 4:00 p.m.
game it's just and I have not I have not
thought about this at all you're just
doing on the floors on the fly that's
how playoff points where I am gonna go
those jacks that was that game the other
a couple years ago is like 45 42 or
something right I am going to go buy
that time of the year
I'm gonna go Steelers Steelers sneaking
one out on the road in Jacksonville here
I was gonna bet against the Steelers
this year and now I'm loving now you got
them in the second round Jets at Chiefs
Chiefs that's a real tough tough road
for the for a young quarter because
nothing I like more than the Saturday of
wild card watching the cheese beat a
team 32 3 it's like every year I'll go
yeah I'll go and Chiefs and then we've
got really exciting next weekend because
we're gonna have Chiefs at Pat's a
review of the of the AFC Championship
game from last year and then on the
other side we got Steelers at Ravens the
classic AFC North I mean this would if
this shook out like this I feel like the
Commissioner of the NFL and whoever
makes his money off of TV advertising
would just be like smiling from ear to
ear here Chiefs that Pats and Steelers
at Ravens all right so Chiefs at Pats
first it's in New England we've seen
that patch from Holmes can play there
but it's Patriots off a bye it's six
degrees because that's the Saturday
night game and I'd love to predict an
upset but I have the Patriots win in
that game okay I'll take it
Steelers at Ravens that's just I mean
the hardest hitting game nine guys are
getting carted off the fight you know
and I'm wearing a yellow black and white
t-shirt you are yes it's in Baltimore
I'll have an extra week the Steelers
were just bashing around with the
Jaguars you know it's gonna be a tough
physical team yeah you could say the
Steelers like we're just limping to the
finish line on this one they squeak one
out against a hard-hitting Jaguars team
like they could be pretty banged up
whereas the Ravens could be looking for
the same point in primetime
the Steelers have owned the Ravens in
years past true it's a shocking
statistic when you look at it at the end
though I think that the one issue that
the Steelers will have every year is the
depth of their D line towards the end of
the year they they were like too much on
stuff on to it they were like too much
on Cameron Hayward and I'm gonna have my
top two seeds advanced Patriots and
Ravens okay so that sets us up for a
Pats at Ravens playoff game which we've
seen over the years we've seen a few
times which is another great rivalry
sure we saw them destroy the Patriots
like 34 14 that one year we saw the
missed field goal so that the Patriots
132 27 we saw the almost interception to
end it it was like sterling Brown
knocking the ball out of lis something's
hand Patriots are going to the Super
Bowl Patriots that Ravens the Patriots
squeak it out I saw wasn't tweet the
other day I would pick the Patriots to
win the Super Bowl but it's a boring pic
I'm trying to be right he's trying to be
correct now yeah yeah my press anybody
if you want to pick a crazy Defensive
Player of the Year candidate sure that's
by the way that's that's what I'm trying
to be right that's a gambling discussion
right like it's it's a lot of fun to say
like hey you know who might win MVP this
year Lamar Jackson I don't think he's
gonna win but it's probably a very sexy
good odds type pick and you'd be going
against the grain by by suggesting it
okay I may or may not have put down
money on Damian Lillard to be the MVP
next year in the NBA just because the
odds were really cool yeah I was like 32
or something noise yeah all right so
what do you think of my playoff when I
was 22 sorry um I like it because the
Patriots end up in the Super Bowl so
what am I gonna say no there's just that
team man okay
NFC NFC this is your division the NFC
East we've got the Eagles oh hold on I
need I need can you can you stall for 15
seconds you want to vamp I just want you
to vamp for 15 seconds because like this
wild card is [ __ ] let me actually how
about this as we go through the
divisions I'm gonna say there's a
possible wild card and then I'm gonna
figure it out the end after I talk about
can I get people some cooking tips for
the next 15 seconds or do you need me to
talk about football okay oh just that
you can buy ramen packets from the store
and then you can turn them into really
gourmet stuff by making your own like
you put some chicken in a marinade cut
up some vegetables put it all together
with some sesame oil and then throw in
the packets from the ramen impact
doesn't have to be a 60 cent meal
ideally you were gonna tell me the
secret way to cut Tomatoes and I got by
Top Ramen that's good okay the one team
excuse me I have
tootie I have a possible wildcard team
which means is it possible to okay I
have the Eagles winning this division
okay it's there there are too many
things that are pointing me to the
Eagles I think the Eagles are the
deepest team in the NFL they have the
number one offensive line
according to Brandon thorns offensive
line statistics they have the third
easiest strength of schedule
it went up 15 spots from last year
massive jump
they were -6 and 20 18 turnovers they
were six and six and one score games I
look at the Eagles I really think other
than Carson Wentz they could lose their
number one guy at every position and
still be fine that's how good the Eagles
are in my mind yeah a lot of depth they
are a minus 110 so you're basically
getting you know you bet $110 to win a
hundred year if you call it a coin flip
if you think the Eagles are better than
a coin flip to win the division then you
bet on them to win the division and in
fact I actually took them at minus 150 I
got okay so yes the element worse odds
so that means that the public has been
betting the Cowboys over the last couple
of weeks then yes that at certain
casinos it's hard to get good odds sure
if I if I if my company wasn't aligned
with another casino I probably would
have shot the line but I had to do it it
understood yes okay so the two teams
that I do not have making the playoffs
Washington and New York yeah Washington
four and two and one score games last
year they do have the 11th easiest
schedule in the NFL plus seven in 2018
turnovers in the end I don't know what's
happening with their left tackle Trent
Williams I have issues up and down their
offensive line right now I find them to
have no weapons at wide receiver they're
apparently shopping they're number one
wide receiver and Josh Thaksin Case
Keenum to Dwayne Haskins I do like their
defense a lot I find Greg Mineski be a
very unheralded defensive coordinator I
do like their defensive line with Geron
Payne and Jonathan Allen and Matt in8 is
from Ryan Anderson Ryan Kerrigan but
they're just not a winning team they're
just I just when I know that I can spend
time not thinking about a team I don't
the Redskins are at plus 900 to win the
division and Giants have plus 1200 to
win the vision so Vegas agrees Giants
are a better bet there if you want to
throw $20 on the Giants what would you
get back for that
well if you're it's a hundreds 12 to one
so you'd be getting at 200 240 240 not
bad for a $20 bet I'm not making that
bet but there's a lot of positive
regressions for the Giants 6 easiest
schedule in the NFL 4 and 8 in one score
games last year and if you believe that
Eli or Daniel Jones will be an
improvement on Eli with say Quan and all
that I just I think their defense will
be markedly improved
I think the Giants I might even pick
them to beat the Cowboys in week one
I think their defensive front seven
adding in the Marcus Golden's the Dexter
Lawrence's adding a DeAndre Baker in the
back Antoine Bethea I think their
defense is gonna be a lot better I do
not trust their offensive line I do not
trust their quarterback play I do not
think any of their wide receivers
including Golden Tate I think golden
dates can have one of the most
disappointing years ever hmm misses for
games what it's just a bummer I like him
the reason the Cowboys are on my wild
card bubble 9 and 3 and 1 score games
last year I cannot get that out of my
head I just I also look at their
offensive coordinator and Kellen Moore
the only system he's worked under is
Jason Garrett so how much different is
this offense gonna be this year I don't
know I don't know if Zeke's gonna play I
have a lot of questions there Amari
Cooper's foot things kind of messing me
up the other issue that I have with this
team is I know that this offensive line
is healthy and if they're healthy
according to Brandon thorn second best
offensive line in the NFL Tyron Smith
has missed a number of games the last
few years I worry about that Robert
Quinn is suspended for the first two
games - Marcus Lawrence is coming off of
shoulder surgery and the pro football
doc is saying he probably won't be right
until October their number one
cornerback Byron Jones had hip surgery
this offseason he has excuse me he
hasn't even stepped on the field yet
there's a number of guys in this team
from how is Zeke gonna be right away
Robert Quinn suspension - Marcus
Lawrence that I'm just worried about the
regression and the injuries that's why
they're a bubble team for me well
back to them later I just see Ezekiel
Elliott coming onto this field signing
some new contracts 72 hours before the
first game and just being gangbusters he
could just dragging this team to 11 wins
I'm just saying that last time he missed
a lot of time he came in with a belly
and he's been in Cabo and I know he's
training with Marshall Faulk and I know
that he's the kind of guy that you give
him six days he's in the greatest shape
of his life I just know that the other
thing that pushed it down was Jerry
Jones coming out and saying we just need
Zeke for the playoffs
Zeke plays if Jerry Jones buckles Zeke
does not play because Jerry Jones if if
if Zeke buckles he's not going to buckle
but when Jerry Jones comes out and goes
in order to get a year of eligibility he
has to come back by week ten
I could see Zeke really doing what
Kareem hunts doing right now
missed the first nine weeks and then
play weeks 10 through 16 freshman that's
the case Cowboys might be six and four
in the first ten you know so I just if
they don't have a seat for an extended
period of time that I'm hedging my bets
by making them a bundle team so I'll get
back to them in a little for sure ready
to move on to the NFC North yes Chicago
Bears have the best odds at plus 160
then the Packers at plus 195 then the
Vikings at plus 240 and everyone's
forgettin about the Detroit Lions at
+1000 okay so I have a possible wild
card in this just one the team that I
think is on the low end is the Detroit
Lions they were -5 in turnovers last
year two and four and one score games
I watched them I think that my big issue
with them is they need this defense to
be incredible they need Matt Patricia's
defense to be unbelievable the problem
is Trey flowers coming off all seasons
shoulder injury - Sean hand has a hand
issue right now Mike McDaniels got cut
from the Packers because he was dealing
with a foot and I don't think this
defense is gonna be that incredible
right away
and I don't like Darrell Bevell as an
offensive coordinator because of that
I'm out okay that was my that was your
lions spiel that was my
Shark Tank see how that was your pitch
can I buy 15 percent of that take so I
have the Vikings missing the playoffs I
do not have them on the bubble
I think the Vikings are a very good team
I think their offensive line is getting
really a lot better
I think Kirk Cousins is gonna have a
very good year I think davon cooks gonna
be really good
dig steel and all the pieces are there
finally an athletic tight end a backup
Kyle Rudolph and Irv Smith my issue with
the Vikings is always the same issue
depth their season schedule gets a lot
harder
it goes from eighth easiest last year to
19th also their defense faces the ninth
most difficult offenses there's also a
trend online right now of people going
is anyone talking about the fact that
Xavier Rhodes has fallen off a cliff in
his PFF rankings concerns me a lot the
other thing that happened is this that I
saw since 2014 the Vikings have played
11 outdoor road games what do you think
their records been in those games oh God
I'm assuming really bad if she's right
and against the spread 2 & 9 oh 10 and 1
if though the tie was against the
Packers last year they have not won a
road game outdoors in five years this
year they played Green Bay Chicago
Kansas City Seattle and the Chargers all
outdoors that [ __ ] matters to me it just
does when you have statistics like that
it impacts me now they do have five
games this year where they have a rest
advantage where like they play a teen
than that team played on Monday Night
Football er they played on Thursday
Night Football all that I just I look at
the Vikings and I worry about the depth
of that defense like I always do and I
know that Kevin Stefanski was good for
the last few weeks last year but I don't
know how good as offense is going to be
as a whole we haven't seen it so I'm I'm
I'm gonna have to pull out that leaves
us with the Bears and the Packers
I have the Packers winning the NFC North
I respect that okay three and six and
one score games last year seventh best
offensive line they do face the second
toughest run defenses in the NFL this
year what's really scary is their last
11 games they face two teams that are
coming off of a bye
they face two teams that are coming off
a Thursday Night Football and there's
one game where they have a short week so
their rest averse for a lot of those
games and their strength of schedule is
15th I just look at this team and I see
all of the depth on the defensive line
their linebackers are a [ __ ] mess the
NFC North is tough to pick but in the
end it's Aaron Rodgers healthy I'm
betting on Aaron Rodgers and most
excitingly you know how they do those
throwback jerseys the Packer is actually
going to be playing some of their home
games in a denim jersey with denim pants
top which is really exciting I'll be
amazing the reason the Bears are a
bubble team right now to make the
playoffs is there are so many regression
number one Vic Fangio is gone I don't
want anyone to tell me that Chuck Pagano
is just as good he's not article came
out on ESPN Insider interviewing Sean
McVeigh Kyle Shanahan and Matt Lafleur
they all said the toughest guy to
prepare for is Vic Fangio okay three of
the up-and-coming offensive minds that
were waxing poetic he's gone some big
loss the Bears were the third healthiest
team in the NFL last year that will
likely regress yeah do you buy that in
terms of I know you you're talking
regression a lot today injury that you
can have a lot of bad luck with injury
and then the next year be totally fine
the way I look at it is I look for teams
that were an extreme if you were really
healthy hmm you're gonna get a bit more
injured and if you're the Falcons and
like your entire defense was gone
devastated yeah I have to imagine gonna
be a little bit better but teams like
the Chargers I don't because their
madness right the Bears have the fifth
hardest schedule in the NFL it dropped
26 spots they were a top they were the
third
see schedule last year they dropped down
26 spots so they're there another
Houston Texans type of team they were
plus 12 and turnovers last year they
were six and four in one score games
they have a middle run in their schedule
this year where for the five teams they
play are Saints Chargers Eagles Rams
they finish with Cowboys Packers Chiefs
Vikings like I look at this team I look
at Mitchell true Biscay I I think that
their defense is gonna be good I think
their offense is gonna be good but
Mitchell sure Biscay on the road with a
much harder schedule there schedule was
so much easier last year they were able
to coast through a lot of their wins the
Bears are on the bubble and I don't know
if I got them in the wild-card but I'll
reserve that too when we get to the
bracket okay I the Packers winning and
the Bears is my bubble team so so far we
have the Eagles and Packers somewhere in
the like two three seed range yes the
Cowboys are making the playoffs and the
Bears you're not quite sure yet is that
right copy that okay now let's move on
it's interesting to you talking about
division with us sure I get lost when
when like three or four names come in a
row because I just as much as I follow
the league I just can't name all four
defensive tackles on a given team I
sometimes on the Patriots I can't even
say what the Bears but I was saying
about those team you mean like names of
players or names of teams
yeah just like III sometimes I just
can't keep up with the with the name
when there's a list of names yes like
listening to - you talk probably to
Warren sharp when is this going to be
like and this person and this person in
this person that over this year the
linebacking core is this person this
person this person I just I just don't I
just don't have the recall for that
totally it's a skill I'm impressed by it
let's go to the South NFC South we've
got the Saints are the favorites at
minus 160 very heavy favorites there a
lot of big then the Falcons at plus 320
the Carolina Panthers at plus 450 and
the Bucs at plus 1200 okay I do have a
bet here for one of these teams so I
have
- with a possible third in the NFC South
Wow a lot of people are very how in the
East they were very how the West I'm
kind of feeling the South okay
the team that is not making the playoffs
at all Tampa Bay Buccaneers yeah that
doesn't surprise but here's the deal
they are gonna [ __ ] up some teams this
year four and seven and one score games
Bruce Arians has never won less than six
games and their over-under is six and a
half so I would bet the over if I was
the Bucs turnovers last year the Bucs
were minus eighteen and they faced the
softest past defenses in the NFL this
year so by Evans by Godwin by OJ Howard
they faced the surfaced past events of
the enough and I recall you being higher
than some on Jameis is a fantasy q yeah
a lot of inada numbers for him like
4,000 yards passing type type of season
my problem is is that I know a lot of
people I don't think the offensive line
is that great and Bruce Arians wants his
quarterbacks to sit in the pocket and
Jameis Winston sitting in the pocket for
too long just doesn't sound good to me
here's what I think is the death blow
for the Buccaneers weeks four to nine
they do not have a single home game and
they have a trip to London that's crazy
the only thing that's interesting is
they're one of only three teams last
year that were better on the road than
at home I don't know why but I look at
the Buccaneers and there's just a lot of
holes I don't like their defensive line
via vias hurt Levante David damn
Buchanan Justin Evans I'm not buying the
Bucks now the team that I believe is
winning the division is a team that I
bet in Vegas I got a minus 130 over
eight the Carolina Panthers
I have winning the NFC South well if you
believe in them then that is a very
tasty yeah what's their division line
plus 450 so $100 to win four hundred and
fifty dollars what's your initial
reaction that Cam Newton heat when he
went healthy he puts up
and there was just that that season he
went 15 and one I don't know why he
couldn't do that again what I've from
reading pro-football doc that there are
certain surgeries that the second
surgery the first surgery you think
you're good the second surgery fixes it
mmm there are some surgeries where the
first season you can play but the second
season you can really play ACL is the
latter Allen Robinson could play last
year first year of an ACL he's gonna be
back to his old self
this season shoulder injuries with
quarterbacks that first surgery you
think you can play the second surgery
you're good to go
hmm so I look at the Panthers and they
have a ninth best oh line they're
getting Darryl Williams healthy they
drafted Greg little Matt paradise
paradise is back and Trey Turner
I like their offensive line the thing
that is selling me on the Panthers they
may have the deepest front 7 in the NFL
other than the Ravens which is why I
like both teams I'm gonna do a little
name listing here in the middle I'll go
slow in the middle
Don Terry Poe koans shirt these are
these are Pro Bowl names Gerald McCoy
member they got him from the Bucks Egan
Vernon Butler first-round pick
that's just your two deep defensive
tackles you had in Kyle love was a good
player your middle linebackers are Luke
Kuechly and Shaq Thompson ballers and
your pass rushers bro Bruce Irvin this
kid Brian burns who they got in the
first round this year looks like a stud
and Mario Addison they are gonna make
their secondary so much better by the
amount of of pass rush that they're
gonna get a lot of cubies with happy
feet and I look at McCaffrey and DJ moai
I am all in on the Panthers this year so
they were three and seven and one score
games they face the third easiest pass
defenses this year so Cam Newton should
be able to go off and they were the
eighth most injured team in the NFL last
here so I think they get positive
regression now I do have one team locked
into a wild card and one team a bubble
the team I have locked into a wild card
is the Saints and I thought about not
making them allowed hmm here's the
Saints have the 18th easiest schedule in
the NFL they were plus eight and
turnover last year they were five and
two in one score games which I do not
like the Saints last year one how many
games I was like 13 12 13 there are a 10
win team this year their line in Vegas
is 10 and a half I would bet the under
the Saints in my mind are a 10 win team
and wild card or a 9 win team and
missing the playoffs but the reason I
have them locked in is of all the other
teams that are fighting for a wild-card
spot I have a hard time thinking drew
Brees and Sean Payton aren't making the
playoffs I just have a hard time the
number one thing I'm looking at for the
Saints this year they have the third
best offensive line the NFL corner
Brandon thorn however last year four
different guys on that ol line missed a
combined 11 games with injury and there
do not have max Unger anymore at center
they have Erick McCoy but Andrus peat
missed games last year with injury
Terron Armstead missed games with injury
Ryan Rams check missed games with injury
Larry Warford missed games with injury
if the Saints offensive line starts
getting banged up those guys are not
spring chickens they've played a lot of
snaps it won't matter how good your
breezes he will not have the time it
won't matter how good Alvin camara is
and when I look at their defense I think
they have some very good players Sheldon
Rankin's coming off in Achilles but I
don't think they're that deep and the
Saints are there they're my five seed
but a little bit worried I just want I
want to hear from Drew Brees in the
playoffs that's what I want yeah one
signature in the playoffs cuz I keep
hearing rumblings that this might be
Drew Brees his final season that he
might hang it up after this year I want
to hear from him I'm not necessarily
saying he's going to the Super Bowl I
want to have a signature Drew Brees
2020 in January
playoff game where he throws for 360
yards and four touchdowns and just has a
couple of those breezy throws over the
middle that are just so sick and we can
we can say hey man great career you want
a Super Bowl you're a great guy this is
gonna be a two hour podcast of really
I'm just gonna go quickly the reasons
why I have the Falcons as a positive
team this year insanely injured last
year should come back playing in a dome
for their first nine games 13 of their
16 games in a dome
Ryan Matt Ryan averages almost 0.7 more
yards per attempt indoors than outdoors
if you were to bet Matt Ryan as MVP it
would make a lot of sense to me right
now
I get it they face the sixth easiest
passed defenses this year again Matt
Ryan looking good in their last five
games against their bucks their five and
OH in the last seven games against the
Panthers they're six and one now all of
the track record for the Falcons says
positive there on the bubble right now
with the Bears and the Cowboys for that
last NFC spot that's what I'm trying to
figure out right now Matt Ryan twenty
five to one MVP odds by the way it's
[ __ ] something very juicy very juicy
should we jump over to the NFC West okay
I hope you guys are enjoying this we're
taking along what we're gonna put all of
the time codes that says by division yes
so you can listen to the division and
everyone's listening to this thing at
1.5 X speed like they're not spending a
full two hours I hope so I've just
discovered 1.5 Rams - 180 Seahawks + 285
Niners plus 500 and Cardinals at plus
2500
one team LA Rams that's it and I did bat
in Vegas Seahawks not to make the
playoffs and I got that at minus 165 but
I bet it okay I have the Rams in because
I think they're they're they're they all
the signs point to them having a drop
but they have the seventh easiest
schedule in the NFL turnovers were plus
11 hate that six and one in one score
games hate that they were the healthiest
team in
NFL the last three years hate that but
I'm still putting them in sometimes you
just do it they got a great coaching
staff they've got great infrastructure
they got Wade Phillips they there's just
too much talent it just feels like a
really talented team every year I am
gonna kick myself later these are the
other things that scare me goth at home
he's touchdown interception ratio as 22
to 4 on the road he's 11 to 10 I have
circled certain things that I'm going to
remind myself betting during the year
and one of them is Goff on the road I'm
gonna be betting heavily against the
Raiders the Rams on the road just one
thing but the three z'n I do like the
Rams is they face five teams with a rest
advantage they face the Saints the
Browns the Niners and the Seahawks all
huge games after those teams are on
Monday Night Football
Sean McVeigh an extra day to prepare to
against another coach that's a huge
benefit in my mind the team they face
after they have their own by the
Steelers another huge game where Sean
McVeigh has more time to prepare that's
the reason I the Rams going in and they
have the best player of the NFL and
Aaron Donald they have an offense that
will figure it out they're gonna be good
should we go through the seeds let me
just quickly I know I'm going forever
yet please
I think the Niners are a seven eight win
team they have incredible regression
their strength of schedule improved by
11 their turnovers they were minus 25 in
turnovers last year under hurled
unheralded crazy three and six and one
score game's fourth most injured team
last year and this year they faced the
easiest run defense as the NFL
I have drafted Matt Breda as much as I
can or Tevin Coleman but I think that
the Seahawks that the Niners are better
but I do not think that they're going
for a wild-card spot the Cardinals they
are face the easiet there's just so much
[ __ ] I just don't buy the Cardinals they
don't look good I'm not gonna get in the
statistic let's give let's give Kyle
Emory a big playground this year like
you don't worry about making the
playoffs just give us a couple of
electrifying runs and a couple of crazy
passes so that we
you're in your second year as left go
loves you in your second year as a
starting quarterback that's when you'll
go for the playoff run our offensive
line stings I'll entrust our offensive
coordinator I'm just gonna say the
Seahawks the reason I had them falling
off I don't have the Seahawks in the
playoffs because they had the 20th
easiest strength of schedule and went
down six from last year they were plus
15 in turnover margin plus 15 were the
highest in the NFL that's regressing to
the mean and not only that their wins
were completely reliant on turnovers
when they won the turnover battle by two
or more there were four and one getting
those games are hard if they were tied
in the turnover margin or less they were
two and four they also faced in the
first six weeks without Geron read with
their defensive line being completely
banged up a number of injuries to their
secondary in the first six weeks they
faced these four teams Pittsburgh good
offense Saints good offense Rams good
offense Browns good offense
I think the Seahawks start really slow
this season and they're not able to claw
back as all those other guys get back
that's why the Seahawks missing the
playoffs Wow
so it's either the Falcons the Cowboys
or the Bears for that final wild-card
spot would you like to make a plea for
one of those teams you listen to me make
the pitches for those three teams which
one sounded the best it doesn't seem
like it's gonna be the playoffs unless
Eddie Panero is kicking clutch kicks so
I feel like this is a Chicago Bears I'm
not making like just a joke Freddy
Panero I just do feel like the Bears
have such a strong defense
Khaleel can win you I don't know two and
a half games by himself this year with a
couple of strips acts that defense is so
strong mr. Biscay I mean you talked
about from gone from what year one to
year two there's also the year from year
to to year three jump where now it's he
feels like he's got the keys to this
team right he he can scamper around he
can mess with defensive coordinators
they got a lot of weapons
I think the Bears sneak into the
playoffs I actually have them winning
that division so
that's your prerogative man it's your
show it's a lot of a lot of thought
coming out of his brain right now I'm
going Falcons I respect three teams from
the NFC South it says it's happened
before yeah my main reason is the
cowboys and bear the cowboys have
historic regression one score game plus
I don't know about Zeke and all the
injuries on defense
the Bears have historic strengths over
schedule flips plus all of the other one
score games turnovers and all that and
they're losing Vic Fangio and the
Falcons while they have a tougher
schedule they had all those injuries
last year all the games in the dome Matt
Ryan healthy all those weapons I'm
playing the regression trends this year
I like him that's that have your wisdom
and stick to it it's a good system okay
it's a good system it's a system so that
means that I have this many new teams in
the playoffs this year I have the
Jaguars in the playoffs they weren't
there the Jets and the playoffs they
weren't there and then the NFC I had the
Packers they weren't in the playoffs
last year the Panthers weren't in the
playoffs last year and the Falcons so
five teams that weren't in the playoffs
last year I have in and I was shooting
for five or six yeah it's about what the
averages every year there's about six
five is six issue of turnovers so let's
do the seeds okay so your division
winners are Packers Eagles Rams Panthers
I don't see any of them was like running
away with 14 or 15 guys oh my one scene
okay and I have them probably went about
12 mm-hmm the Panthers are my two seed
mm-hmm the Rams are my three seed Rams
is the three seed and that means the
Packers is the four see they're okay
Saints are my five Falcons are my six
rate so wildcard weekend we've got
Falcons at Rams I want to go back and
see
the things that I wanted to talk about
and we've got Saints at Packers - very
fun games
all right so our very lively
quarterbacks and so I have the Patriots
in the Jets in the Eagles in the Rams in
so I have four teams from the top ten
Sophists and then I did put Atlanta and
Kansas City and so that's two of the
hardest second-year quarterbacks I have
the Jets and the Ravens making it I do
not have the bills in the Browns I have
them just missing okay all right so
what's our wildcard weekend Falcons at
Rams that could be 38:37 shootout so
we've seen this two years ago right
Falcons went to LA and won
let's go Rams okay Rams take it I would
imagine in a wild-card weekend like that
they're the three seed let's say they've
got like two or three more wins than the
sixth seeded Falcons they're probably
like three and a half four point
favorites or something like that they
should win that game at home Saints at
Packers again I want to hear from Drew
Brees this is a great like to legendary
quarterbacks going at it and wildcard
weave outdoors outdoors at Bukit packers
okay so that means ours book it outdoors
that's the key now we're looking at the
next weekend by the end of the year drew
Brees arms a noodle Packers at Eagles
would be the 4l to one hand and then
Rams at Panthers would be your other
game yeah I kind of I kind of wanted it
to end up being Saints Rams like revenge
good alright so what was where what are
the Rams Packers at Eagles and then Rams
at Panthers Panthers Panthers take that
one I can't believe this I love Baylor's
a lot of rest and then Packers at Eagles
Eagles coming off when you just
described as a 12 win one seed type
season as Aaron Rodgers go into Philly
and take it himself so here's what I'm
thinking I hate it I love Aaron Rodgers
but I hate him against my Eagles course
he's really good at tearing up that Jim
Schwartz defense he's got the offensive
line I don't think the Eagles pass rush
is that good and it's gonna come down to
[ __ ] I'm a fan Eagles I was gonna fake
the Packers just and that's fine I have
my one in two seed in both conferences I
don't like but that happens almost every
year there's one in two seeds in the in
the title games a lot yeah Panthers at
Eagles for our NFC Championship game at
that point if you're picking your Eagles
all the way yeah let's go the Eagles
rematch the Super Bowl two years here we
go Patriots versus Eagles in the Super
Bowl Eagles were in the Super Bowl and
the Eagles win it again damn I can't
yeah I'm doing it you know why I want my
pick to be the Eagle
so that I can follow him all year but
also I don't think it's crazy to pick
the Eagles know and then Carson Wentz
gets the Super Bowl title that he
probably could have won a couple of
years ago okay you have a couple of
months to change your pic no this is it
lock it in this is it you can't make any
sort of decision
oh no I'll change throughout the year
that guys are gonna get injured teams
are gonna surprise the Super Bowl pick
is the Eagles the Eagles that's never
changing all right hit me up guys on
social let me know kind of like who
you're picking and and where I went
wrong and all that stuff I do have my
MVP and I do have my Defensive Player of
the Year who is your we're gonna play
Defensive Player of the Year I know I'm
putting you on the spot Khalil Mack I am
picking Myles Garrett yeah it's a good
one I believe that the Browns are gonna
are gonna be right in the playoff hunt
all year I've already told you that I
think that they're there their strength
of schedule for the defense's gets a lot
easier and I think Myles Garrett starts
off the huge week one against Tennessee
and they're carrying the offense and
people are expecting Baker to carry it
but it's actually miles that counter
he's got like 20 sacks this year my MVP
I'm going Ben Roethlisberger okay I
think that the storyline of being by
himself with no Antonio Brown and no
Le'Veon Bell is going to be a storyline
that a lot of people are gonna grasp on
to I think Ben has a big year
statistically when you factor in the
strength of schedules that they're
facing and you factor in that people are
gonna expect the Steelers to drop off
they faced again the fifth easiest run
defenses I think Ben is gonna work
harder this year than he ever has I
think he puts up like a forty one
touchdown seven interception season the
offensive lines healthy Connor
JooJoo has a big year I think it's the
storyline that propels Big Ben to win an
MVP and I have them as a fifth I have
them as like an 11 win five seed yeah I
mean if they lose two of the best skill
position guys in the world over two
seasons and Big Ben's still dry
- eleven wins that's a that's a
narrative that wins you an MVP alright
so those are my bets
those are my division winners and my
Super Bowl winners and my MVP I went on
the limb for a number of it I I will
never play this safe I'm going to be
keeping track of everything all year but
these are my pigs and I thought it was
important for the gambling show
throughout the year to have someone on
that has a bona fide expert have someone
that I believe is the number one person
in the space so that when I am making
the picks with the super contest or left
coast locks or whatever it is I need
someone here that's gonna provide value
for the 33% and that is why my it is my
honor and my privilege to toss to an
edit where I made a phone call where I'm
gonna call that guy and you're gonna
hear it so I love you guys a lot and
here is our new gambling expert hey
who's this Warren I'm recording you on
the podcast through my phone so you're
on the pod right now I just wanted to
officially introduce you to the
wonderful 33% that every podcast that
will come out on Fridays during the
season that will be our big gambling
show against the spread you are going to
be joining me and I could not be happier
yeah enough about them but really I'm
trying to get really better at betting
on did you know I'm in the super contest
this year thank you
so usually I would do left ko locks
which were four picks a week but now the
super contest I got to do five so I
think that you and me talking about line
movements
the week home dogs these guys have heard
me for a very long time pretend to know
what I'm talking about and now I get to
use you as the guy that sets me and all
the crazy people out there straight I
just can't wait to dive into your brain
warrant what could be coming down the
pike why things going to be a great
opportunity and I love the fact that
it's later in the week so that we'll be
able to exact because I know that you're
going to be locked in a cave for four
days poring over film and analytics and
the fact that I get to talk to you on
Thursday and it comes out Friday means
that we're it's gonna be like a
well-cooked steak perfectly done I like
that it sounds like you're actually
excited
I think the 33% scan appreciate that
you're the [ __ ] man dude I have a
safe flight I know you're gonna be on
national TV the rest of this week but
I'm pumped man can't wait to start next
week man what that moustache and that
blazer dude it could be happening soon
all right brother talk soon so that is
the guy that we're gonna have on
Thursdays Warren freakin sharp I'm super
excited you know why don't we just go
and bring in David at this point too and
I've been waiting for that one for a
long time because I truly believe that
what I call Warren the sharpest mind in
football I know it's a play on words
I also believe that I think that I've
been paying attention to the football
space now for a long time and of
everyone that I've met there are certain
people they get admiration from all Mena
Kimes is the most liked person in NFL
media 11 yeah Evan Silva I think is the
most trusted mind in fantasy sports and
I believe that when it comes to
analytics and gambling and trends and
and the future of football I think
Warren is the guy and the fact that
we've been talking behind the scenes now
for a few months and we've been like man
we need to figure out a way to get this
together the 33% has been so
unbelievably kind to him that I think he
was excited and when he says we want to
give the 33 percent what they deserve
Warren is not one of these guys like I'm
a marketing hype kind of guy he's like
they deserve to be informed and what I
really care about on this show is people
that that care as much as me and he
might care more than me which is [ __ ]
crazy so I'm so excited you know the
difference between a sort of bombastic
media personality and a true analytics
person is the analytics person just
wants the most people to have the most
objective information at their
fingertips and that's what he loves to
do he he really gets a rush from having
more people be more informed and what
you do with that information is totally
up to you I'm place bets however you
want you can use your gut if you think
that you know going for it on 4th and 2
is a bad move like whatever it is but he
just wants to show you that here's the
data because it is factual and it is
true and I have spent my years going
over it and here it is on a platter for
you my friend you know he's coming in
without any BIOS right like and I've
never been around someone like that
that's a true numbers person that's a
Bill James school of thought loves
numbers and what I'm excited about is in
terms of everyone gets to use the
information however they want I think
there's been a lot of value to a lot of
listeners over the years when I hear
information and I go I'm taking it this
way a lot of the 33% over the years have
gone when you take it that way I always
know your biases and I can play against
you and his own
weird way you're gonna get Warren sharps
analytic the old left co faithful go in
the wrong way zag and zig and and I
think that we're gonna really try and
teach this year not about how to make a
bet or what does this mean we're gonna
get really deep inside the numbers and I
know how much the betting show has meant
to the 33 percent and I really believe
this is the next step it's the evolution
of the gambling show and you know we're
still gonna be putting about Friday's
which means that the Thursday night game
we're gonna go hey I probably think that
the Packers are gonna win this one and
then you're gonna hear me be wrong then
it's gonna completely throw off
everything for the rest of the gambling
show but couldn't be more excited to get
Warren involved what I just record it
like 1:00 a.m. Eastern on Thursdays then
no okay all right so that's it for now
hope you guys like the pics that I did a
little bit earlier super excited about
Warren Sharpe and we are gonna have
another co-host I'm just now putting the
cart before the horse so there's
exciting things brewing I just can't say
anything guys you're gonna have to tune
in next week we are on the cusp of going
to three shows a week
I know it's Labor Day so we're only
gonna have two next week
one that comes out on Wednesday and one
that comes out on Friday so the one on
Wednesday I'll try and predict
bears-packers the the season opening
game also starting next Wednesday night
D the P hashtag D the P I know you guys
saw the clip of Mohamed Sanu
much more to come ditch the playbook mr.
Engler over here has been locked in a
room editing stuff so I'm very excited
for you guys to see it and I'm excited
to get this show and this season
rolling for David Ingeborg lefke it's
been a delight just getting this ditch
the PlayBook up and you know what if
you've got an idea for a web series just
go out and make it that's my advice to
you go out and make the thing that was
your big thank you that a problem for
Warren sharp
I'm Adam left Cody Elias koe man real
holla holla holla at you later
[Music]